joining us now white house press
secretary kelly mcinerney let me let me
first of all say it's a badge of honor
for you congratulations that they don't
like you
i think that i'd celebrate that fact and
i want to go to one piece
you know you one thing was brought up
you don't want to work with reporters
can they first apologize for the year's
worth of lies and conspiracy theories on
russia
before we work with people that are
unwilling to tell the truth themselves
and
don't retract and apologize that's
exactly right
instead of retracting those stories they
won pulitzers
of those stories at the washington post
in the new york times for lying about
the witch-hunt against the president of
the united states they were dead wrong
but they they don't apologize they don't
give back the pulitzers as they should
uh what's so egregious about this sean
uh and particularly with the tom cotton
op ad you know we use the briefings and
we highlight peoples
whose names are not mentioned in many
mainstream publications like david doran
the police officer who lost his life in
the riots and how ironic
that the new york times rather than
highlighting this tragic story that
deserved attention
they instead censor a piece that
mentions and talks about the violence in
the riots and that of course is senator
tom cotton's op-ed it's really egregious
you know the world has changed kaylee
you know rush limbaugh
syndicated in 1988 to only 200 talk
stations it's the number one format and
radio over 3000 now am and fm
the president has 200 and i don't know
the total
in terms of twitter instagram facebook
over 200 plus
million people he can go directly to he
doesn't need them
now you have to many talk radio i
support the president's policies openly
i don't hide it
and i'm proud of it proud of his
accomplishments
you don't really have to talk to these
people anymore does i don't think the
president needs to
ever argue with them again it's a waste
of time you're exactly right and that's
what drives them nuts sean
you have the democrats who engage in
basket of deplorable politics like
hillary clinton we're all in the basket
of deplorables and you have the
washington post saying oh it's actually
more than half of the country
uh that half of trump supporters that
are in the basket of deplorables and you
have the media doing the bidding work
of the left and it drives them nuts that
this president worked around them spoke
directly to the american people more
than 200 million followers
and that direct connection to the
american people is what perturbs them
and drives them to be even more insane
in their coverage of this president
i notice you come in with the binder and
you know when it's a different topic
you're allowed to have notes
it's not like a presidential debate
although why do i suspect that joe
biden's team is going to want
notes and the debates with donald trump
if he even shows up they're trying to
set the stage that he wouldn't
that to me is like checkmate moments
they don't like being called out isn't
that really the truth here they've
always gotten a pass
they don't like preparation they don't
like that this administration has the
facts on their side and
when they come in with a a question
that's designed to attack this president
in an
unfair manner and then we come back with
the facts and we show the american
people the truth of the matter
it certainly drives them nuts but that's
the thing with this president the facts
are on his side he's done great work for
the american people
who he cares deeply about i mean we come
armed to tell the truth of the trump
presidency which is a great story of
success
for the american people i would argue
shattering every record low unemployment
for every demographic group in the
country i would argue the travel ban
and quarantine and subsequent travel
bans huge
we never ran out of ventilators did we
and the
country relied on the white house uh
also defeating the caliphate that biden
and obama didn't
defeat so can you now
just totally bypass them and really not
even have to talk to them
except i mean i guess it's good that you
go in there they'll all have
a nice chat every day it gets
entertaining but i don't think the
president needs the media and i think
the minute that he's gone
they're out of business that's exactly
right if you look at his ratings at
these coronavirus press briefings the
american people tune in because they
want to hear from the president
unfiltered you know you have the media
saying you're not doing enough testing
oh wait we lead the world in testing 60
million tests
you don't have enough ventilators oh
wait we're supplying the world with
ventilators
he speaks directly to the american
people at those 5 pm press briefings
him at his best the american people
recognize it and joe wouldn't have put
the travel ban
in and democrats were teaching donald
trump with a trial
very same time the president was doing
what no other president had done
ten days after the first case that to me
countless life saved
kaylee i don't know how you do it you're
not paid enough i wouldn't be able to do
your job
thank you